can i give you the prognosis of my
[ __ ] though first i would love to
know about the prognosis
i've heard enough election talk let's
talk about your rectum
so i mention it right and they go we
gotta go to the doctor i went over there
today
and my my doctor dr kawashiri can i say
his name
well he just did yeah well he's a great
guy yeah he's good yeah yeah yeah he's
one of the best don't believe it
okay i'll make a living i'll make louder
yeah maybe maybe there's some promotion
there for him oh
does he specialize in asians i mean
i mean with a last name like that you
know what's weird he could
it he could because i go to my doctor dr
o'hullahan he
he specializes in cirrhosis of the liver
yeah maybe i should switch it up yeah
maybe i should get a black doctor or
something it just it seems
could you be a little more woke maybe go
to another race for your doctoring
all right so he goes so he goes uh i
tell him the problem he goes okay so um
and i you know i i i've never been like
one to go
are you sure about bending over like i'm
like you know me
i'm i i jump in there's a party i'll
jump in
so i bend over take my pants off
obviously right and
what did you do first oh that's
interesting that's interesting oh
yeah that's interesting i think i
[ __ ] been i thought that was going to
get a laugh
i thought it was a ridiculous [ __ ]
she's going to break it he just goes
oh that's interesting no no i thought
that was interesting
you know because you're gonna answer
this a normal person would have take
taken the pans off first and then bend
over yeah but what you just
said was i did bend over first
and then took my pants off
that's so [ __ ] weird oh my gosh
i bent over and there was that that that
moment where the doctor goes
you know what i mean oh my god what are
you doing ah
right and i go i know how it works this
is the way i do it
right so i bent over then i like it you
made it weird back
yeah yeah yeah i reversed it on you took
control of the weirdness i like it
now he's weirded out right and he goes
what are you waiting for big boy
[Laughter]
so he does you know he you first you
hear
a noise like something's coming out of a
tube okay
right you right so he has to put the
lube on and whatnot he has the glove on
and then he doesn't um you know he pearl
harbors it
i mean i know he's kawarashiri but
instead of
her alarm was he like he was doing it
around the island he went yeah but he
told you he was doing it
it wasn't a sneak attack it was a it was
no he said hey sit down next to me
because i want a 3-2-1 don't you want a
3-2-1 when it comes to your [ __ ]
someone yelling that out
don't you want that oh there's
opposition i will be entering your
[ __ ]
in three yeah yeah two so i can like
lynch or whatever my body does they
usually say gonna be a little cold
because of the cold he said nothing
you're going to fend over
pressure is a classic medical
and bent over pull the pants out and
then bonsai is what i
come and just any cindy goes
it's just my um index finger right yeah
i got no that was your thumb bro
he thumbed it you're positive i i i i
i don't have reverse you know what i
mean sight reverse sight
i mean i don't have there's a no i don't
know if there's cameras in the room
but i think he [ __ ] thumbed it it
hurt
or i might have a tight [ __ ] or he
has short fingers
i never thought i never thought of the
third [ __ ] option yeah
yeah you could have you've got little
hands maybe he's got little hair you
probably gave him a complex
he came home came home all moody and his
girlfriend's like what's the matter
i don't want to talk about it what's the
matter
it happened again what happened
oh i put my index finger in somebody's
[ __ ] and they were convinced it was
my thumb
you don't understand it's a man thing
okay yeah yeah
baby i might have [ __ ] his day up
but good news is that he i don't know
how he checks but he goes no blood
well you're not going to know for a
while sweetheart no but he goes that's a
big thing he goes if
he goes there's no traces of blood in
the entrance of the calamari
so he's like you know he said that you
know
because i'm going to hawaii friday so i
don't i don't want to be like do i have
colon cancer or
yeah but you can't you're going to need
a colonoscopy you're almost 50.
did you do one yeah it's the easiest
thing ever yeah like okay this is gonna
smell like peppermint and then five
seconds later it's like all right your
ass is great
no problems that's literally what it
feels like yeah but what sucks is
the day of the day before the stuff you
have to drink
is a little bit gross but when you're
weighing that versus die in a ass cancer
it's just like all right yeah i'll
definitely i'll choose this yeah yeah
but dude you literally go to sleep and
it feels like you're asleep for three
seconds and then you wake up
you can't they're done now you're awake
going
[Laughter]
for like 45 minutes or whatever i don't
mean like i don't know how long it was
wow but they do knock you out yeah
you're out
you literally go you're like laying
there you close your eyes and it feels
like three seconds later
and you wake up and it's done
and you know what happened but you don't
remember it so it's it's a little
unsettling
yeah is there like as the day as the day
goes on is there like there was
something up there there's our feelings
of
some intrusion no oh
it's you don't even have like the
usually when you go under general
anesthesia you have like the whole
you know kind of loopy for a couple
hours the propofol you're up and running
as soon as you they pull that thing out
your butt
you're good to go they tell you to drive
your ass home you're like no no no they
had to have somebody with me oh that's
why they didn't give you propofol they
gave me the propofol because i had a